hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday November 26 2008 een what's
going on how how's it going everybody
how are you dude how the [ __ ] [ __ ]
are you well I'm back everybody
vacation is officially over I have [ __ ]
to do every friggin day of this week you
know why why bill because you actually
have to go to work you lazy [ __ ] Hey
f is for family is coming out on Netflix
this Wednesday November 29th
please watch please watch again please
watch with all your friends or don't do
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do I think
it's gonna be I think you're going to
enjoy it you know you're listening to
this I think you'd enjoy it you know
what I would enjoy if somebody could
tell me how I can buy a quality quality
you know what maybe it's just these
[ __ ] headphones maybe it's just this
Jack whatever let's continue promoting
knowing that people can hear me but I
can't hear myself and when you can't
hear yourself how are you going to be
able to open up to others that's the
question that we want to talk about here
today it's gonna be on November 29th
it's [ __ ] gonna be on Netflix alright
that's the deal let's see what we got
here let's try to put this in here and
let's see if this fixes the problem how
about this new headphones you know most
people if they were a professional they
would have hit pause by now That's not
me is it no that's not how bill does it
bill just keeps going and why would you
what do you know it still doesn't
[ __ ] work does anybody know who the
[ __ ] makes a goddamn [ __ ] headphone
jack that's of quality you know you go
down to Guitar Center and you [ __ ]
buy the goddamn [ __ ] mixer and it
works and then everything else [ __ ]
sucks it doesn't make any sense you go
to a Lexus dealership everything's at
the [ __ ] Lexus level
un-fuckin'-believable with this [ __ ]
[ __ ] I've been bitching about this
for [ __ ]
goddamn [ __ ] months you know all the
dumb [ __ ] that I do with my life all the
[ __ ] bars I go into you think one
night you take a [ __ ] night off and
go buy a [ __ ] headphone jack
efforts a family's gonna be a lot of
that if that's what you're into hey does
anybody know where the [ __ ] I can
[ __ ] go and buy some [ __ ] that wasn't
made in China [ __ ] way to say [ __ ]
you to my country is anything made in
this [ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] country
anymore
the fact that this [ __ ] thing I just
bought this and then you can sell this
and who the [ __ ] am I gonna call call
some [ __ ] guy in India who's
pretending like he's here and then he
can do this [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm sorry
sir
I'm sorry you feel that way I understand
get the [ __ ] out of here by the way I
know your name is a Todd oh it feels
good to blow out the lines every once in
a while everybody over over something
that you totally have power over anyways
this is what I do now I just yell at
things
I don't yell at people anymore I just
I'd you know you know I you know I like
I when you yell at an inanimate object
you feel like it's listening you know
cuz it never interrupts you alright
anyways fsor family's gonna be up
November 29th on Netflix please watch it
also the seventh annual Patrice O'Neal
comedy benefit tickets going fast
loving it Tuesday February 19th at 7
p.m. at the City Center in New York City
lineup Jim Gaffigan big Jay oakerson
Gary Gulman Chris red Michelle wolf
sight the sounds rich vos is hosting and
yours too old freckles all [ __ ]
freckles with his fucked-up headphones
I'm not the headphones it's the goddamn
jack just the [ __ ] jack bomp bomp own
sorry anyways so this week I got to do
this this inner this Skype interview
with this coffee company alright and I
[ __ ] hate I hate Skype I [ __ ] hate
e you know what it skypes another one
those [ __ ] things on your computer
that went
you download it every time you turn your
computer on it [ __ ] sticks it's
[ __ ] goddamn face out there it's like
hey did I click on you did I click on
you I got this other thing right I got
you I got this external hard drive thing
I used it one time every time I shut
down my computer and turn it back on
again it's like that [ __ ] you know
you know that person at the party when
you just sitting there like who invited
this guy that that's what all of those
apps are like you know we need to make
sure every time they turn on your
computer that this comes on and we
remind them that it's on your computer
all it makes me want to do is eventually
grab that icon or whatever the [ __ ] you
call it and drag it over the trashcan
and my favorite thing ever is when you
hit delete trash that little poof there
little poof of dust you know would you
like wouldn't it be great if you could
do that to the guy at the party yeah
just [ __ ] big paper mache arrow you
put it on him and you poke him in his
belly he giggles and then he just he
just disappears and he can get back to
the cool conversation he what happened
or maybe you were just sitting there
enjoying yourself in the corner and he
decided that he was gonna be you know
I'm a social guy I'm just gonna come up
and say hello rather than seeing that
somebody clearly is over in the corner
not wanting to talk to anybody I'm gonna
go over there and go [ __ ] talk to him
you know I mean I don't know that I mean
maybe that's just a [ __ ] white thing
the way we [ __ ] walk up to wild
animals and [ __ ] maybe we twits it
starts at the party by going over to the
person in the corner who clearly has
some sort of [ __ ] issues clearly not
a person you want to steer clear of you
gotta walk up you walk up you say hello
and because of the rules of society over
there this guy doesn't rip your [ __ ]
head off
and then you just oh I think maybe I'll
apply the same annoying behavior I use
at a party into the wild maybe I'll do
that
hey polar bear I'm gonna come on be an
open [ __ ] spirit the amount of you
know I follow that discover sharks on
Instagram the amount of [ __ ] [ __ ]
that are so into sharks they're trying
to prove how not dangerous they are and
they're [ __ ] jumping in the water
with them it's like he didn't you didn't
watch the Crocodile Hunter that's what
the [ __ ] he did do you think you know
nature better than that guy dude the way
that guy got killed that was like a
great episode of The Wire you just
didn't see it coming you know what I
mean
all those years [ __ ] with those
ridiculously ridiculously poison snakes
Omega snakes and [ __ ] Australia that
could be take out a small country with
one bite the entire [ __ ] population
and this guy's going over there with his
[ __ ] bootie shorts on with aerobics
socks [ __ ] with these things you
think it one of these days this guy is
gonna get bit and his shapely tan calves
right didn't happen alright maybe it's
gonna be I don't know that what else did
he [ __ ] with some sort of [ __ ] wild
boar that's what you thought was gonna
get him
certainly a [ __ ] crocodile you know
you thought that would get him and one
ended up [ __ ] getting him a goddamn
stingray never saw that coming that was
just like the wire well what's his face
oh my god I forgot the iconic [ __ ]
guy used to rob the drug dealers I'm not
gonna ruin it much spoiler alert it's
been a spoiler alert it's been out for
[ __ ] 15 years or whatever I'm not
gonna ruin the ending but the way that
guy you know what happens to him you
just don't [ __ ] see it coming I don't
even know what I'm talking about anymore
but anyways I'm doing one of my favorite
people one of my favorite podcasts of
all time this Wednesday I'm gonna be on
the Joe Rogan experience I'm also doing
Dice clays podcast later on that day and
I'm finally calling in to spit in
Chiclets on barstool all right I'm
running the gamut the gamut of podcasts
that day I'm doing Kevin and bean on
Friday and that's local out here if you
live in LA local radio I'm sure they
have an app that you can download and
listen to with wherever the [ __ ] you
want to and then what else I got a
couple of Foner's tomorrow but I know
you have to download
[ __ ] Skype so I can do this phone or
today at noon so that I could then
immediately [ __ ] delete it again
don't forget about me I'm on your
computer we know Skype
everybody knows you here everybody knows
you're [ __ ] here you only want one
positive thing I will say about Skype as
I love the phone ring that ball beep
beep a Paul Booth
I don't know what it is about it I like
it I like other than that everything
about it is uh it's [ __ ] annoying get
on I mean anyways how was your
Thanksgiving
cheers to I already talked about
Thanksgiving I forgot I did it on Friday
I talked Friday where do I talk about
let's talk about the debacle if you were
a Wolverines fan that was Michigan Ohio
State Jesus [ __ ] Christ that was just
that was just a sorry [ __ ] they
should have beat him this year they
really should have you know something as
much as the Buckeyes are walking around
that chest puffed out it's like you let
up 40 [ __ ] points I don't know what
you're so excited about [ __ ]
unbelievable man I swear to God if those
[ __ ] didn't get that [ __ ] ridiculous
spot two years ago it would have been a
rivalry again now adidas they just got
the psychological advantage that [ __ ]
gave two years ago when everybody all
the entire officiating squad was from
[ __ ] Ohio I think he got the first
down whatever the [ __ ] it was anyways I
just wanted a game is what I wanted and
I wanted Harbaugh to win one so then he
could have the [ __ ] Urban Meyer
Harbaugh ten years war but now you know
I don't know Urban Meyer has got some
sort of cyst in his head I had no
[ __ ] idea
I didn't know that so it's just like
yeah dude you gotta you got a wife and
kids what are you doing here you know
every time they run the ball for a loss
the guy literally has to [ __ ] bend
over to his ankles he gets headaches
when he flips out it's just like it's
like it's literally a ticking time but
it's a Mize I'm gonna say it's
unsettling to watch you know what I mean
Jesus Christ but then it's like what is
he gonna do just sit at home
with his cyst being Pleasant I mean the
man has to live his [ __ ] life right
anyways what else what have we talked
about we talked about headphone jacks
we've talked about cysts in people's
heads
Patriots Jets that was the one football
game I watched that one and I watched
the watch the end of the Steelers game
that was tough to watch Big Ben lose
that one man I saw two [ __ ] amazing
quarterbacks they have tough games Aaron
Rodgers had that guy open and then Big
Ben you know I'm talking like I would
have [ __ ] made the pass but I'm so
out of it right now like I was actually
rooting for the Steelers because the
Broncos just I [ __ ] hate the Broncos
just because they kicked our ass from
Craig Morton right through John Elway
and I'm still not over it every [ __ ]
time in any to every [ __ ] time we
play him it's always an away game was
always back in their horseshoe back in
the day it'd be freezing [ __ ] cold
out it would start snowing and then we
would just get the [ __ ] kicked out of me
oh and every time we played him it was
just be like you know we had hope and it
had some sort of playoff implications
and then that would be it that's the old
you know that's the old Boston sports
fan as opposed to now where everybody's
I mean anybody born from the 1990 on is
just absolutely spoiled as far as being
paid to us a Boston sports fan which I'm
totally fine with I watched a little bit
of Celtics caught a little bit of the
Bruins versus the Canadiens and I don't
know I just had it I had a great weekend
I really had a great weekend I tell you
oh I think I told you that guys this did
I tell you I took my I told you that
last last week I took my kid to Guitar
Center man it was [ __ ] awesome God
knows we didn't buy any [ __ ]
headphone jacks and those [ __ ] idiots
they're not idiots but you need to know
why you selling [ __ ] that doesn't
[ __ ] work hey Bill why didn't you
keep the receipt and bring it back
alright I never take the receipt I'm not
coming back doesn't [ __ ] work
I'll just yell about it rather than just
getting in my car and solving the
problem you know every time I think I
turned the corner as a person I just
realized oh Jesus it's just like there's
there's another [ __ ] storage shed of
emotional [ __ ] I have to [ __ ] go
through you know if imagine if they
could do that with your personality they
have the storage wars with you right and
they just make you stand in there
there's a middle-aged person they got a
bunch of [ __ ] women out there looking
for a partner and they're just bidding
on it you know and then they just they
open the door and you're [ __ ] stand-in
there with your [ __ ] dad jeans and
your little [ __ ] belly trying to suck it
in and they're just looking in your eyes
you're trying not to look away like some
wild animal [ __ ] you know then they
start bidding on you what do you think
they'd been on you let's just say you
know we'll make it easy
a hundred bucks is like this guy looks
like a winner top shelf Johnny blue I
want to be with this guy and zero was
this guy's a [ __ ] zero
this guy's a loser everything he touches
turns to [ __ ] you know what do you think
you'd be on that I think the only thing
that saves me is I earn a good living if
you take that out of the equation
alright I think I'm in the 30s depending
on how [ __ ] crazy your dad was I
would say I might even drop down into
the 20s
you know I'm looking at an emotional
lottery picked the next season oh by the
way you know I was talking to virzi and
he said I always [ __ ] this guy's that
sake sake want Berkeley was just having
like a career day almost 100 yards in
the first half or some [ __ ] [ __ ]
against the Eagles and then they ran him
four times in the second half and he
just couldn't wrap his head around the
fact it's like dude the Giants are
tanking okay they're not gonna make the
[ __ ] pit tanking
you know the Patriots did it we'd be in
trouble but they're gonna tank people
Hank all right Indianapolis they tank to
get Andrew Luck Peyton Manning came back
hey doctor said I'm good
oh no Peyton were worried about you I
will [ __ ] worried about you the
payton goes on to [ __ ] you know when
a super bowl over there and [ __ ]
denver i love that you have an order
said whenever anybody treats their
superstar with absolute disrespect that
guy ends up in colorado and wins
championships have you noticed that the
[ __ ] canadians all right there scarf
wearing [ __ ] snooty goddamn fans
booed patrick wall i'm gonna say this
again they booed patrick wah a man not
only a hall-of-famer not only winner of
two Stanley Cups at that point that he
changed the position you're talking
about there's a handful of [ __ ] people
in the history of the NHL that can say
that I changed the position that Patrick
was one of them and what did he do he
went to the Colorado Avalanche it won
not one but two [ __ ] Stanley Cups and
all of those [ __ ] pocket square blue
Blanca Rouge [ __ ] sport coat wearing
[ __ ] up there are still sitting there
with the course on up their ass waiting
for another cup twenty five [ __ ]
years later Indianapolis Colts tank a
[ __ ] season so they can get Andrew
Luck what is Peyton Manning go does he
try to pile on in San Francisco when Jim
Harbaugh was there and they were one
[ __ ] piece away no he does not Peyton
Manning says I'm gonna be a [ __ ] man
about this I'm going to the goddamn
Broncos not saying they were bad but
that would have been a lay up in San
Francisco it's tough to say it would
have been a lay up with Jim Harbaugh
laughter that [ __ ] lost the other day
bow and I'll put up and the
unimaginative [ __ ] play calling run
play-action fake third and long let's
throw it way to [ __ ] his way to [ __ ]
his Peyton man and go he goes to Denver
and he goes to not one but two Super
Bowls gets his ass kicked in the first
one by the plane Seattle you know they
were all [ __ ] roided-up but nobody
gave a [ __ ] cuz they're in Seattle
that's not cheating you know that's a
competitive edge right but he comes back
he wins it like the next year of the
year
a year later I forget what should write
another Super Bowl trophy okay
so I'm thinking that the Giants did get
a tank this year then they're gonna go
out they're gonna draft a [ __ ]
quarterback they're gonna tell Eli
winner if not one but two Super Bowls
against Bill Belichick the greatest
[ __ ] coach of all time they're gonna
tell him to hit the [ __ ] bricks away
do you think that man's going not the
Broncos he's gonna shock everybody's
gonna play point guard for the Denver
Nuggets and they win an NBA championship
right sorry
what you're listening to right now is a
man who has a lot of [ __ ] he has to do
this week and he doesn't want to get out
of bed oh I enjoy in my time off oh did
I enjoy it you know but I realized I was
enjoying it too much because I was
continuing to you know have some drinks
have some cigars and what I really
realized it was Bill when you have time
off what you need to be doing is
drinking water and getting eight hours
sleep then you'll actually feel rested
then the vacation won't seem like it
went by too quickly
I realize this last night the last day
of my vacation all right but what I'm
going to do is I'm going to apply the
wisdom that I've learned I can't even
say wisdom because I've learned this
lesson I've learned this lesson more
[ __ ] times and then then Ohio State
has kicked the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of the
Wolverines in the last decade and a half
[Music]
anyways what's gonna happen I'll have
state Overmyer everybody saying is gonna
leave this year hey that's that's not
good for football
you got to mean it was just building up
you know haha Harbaugh has to harvest
whenever I smoke a cigar my voice cracks
the next day
Harbaugh has to [ __ ] it he's got it he's
got to get he's got to beat that guy he
can't take his ball and go home off for
health reasons he can't you know how
about give him [ __ ]
no is that it buddy huh one little
[ __ ] cyst and you're gonna go home
then urban can just walk away going
sixty three whatever they [ __ ] scored
anyways uh Jesus Christ now what do I do
I do with some reads let's do some reads
that's why I'm reading I'm reading on
Sunday Mon home a woman in alright five
reads everybody not one not two like the
Stanley Cups at Patrick Wall one
actually the Canadians are playing good
this year you know you know not good
enough for their fan base because they
expect things I love what a fan base
expects things out of their professional
sports franchise but nothing out of
their own personal lives that right
there that is a true sports fan
all right five butchers box everybody oh
Jesus do I love these guys butcher box
delivers healthy 100% grass-fed and
grass-finished beef free-range organic
chicken and the one the only never to be
replaced the the the [ __ ] pork that
changed the position the Patrick wah of
pork Heritage bread pork now a lot of
you pluck me probably well what exactly
is heritage bread pork and I know if I
explain this well guess what it's so
[ __ ] good I'm gonna explain it again
heritage red pork is is is murdered pigs
that are purebred pigs that you can
trace their family tree all the way back
to Europe they weren't over here [ __ ]
these low-rent pigs here in the United
States of America you know that sit
around watching reality TV while they're
eating cotton candy these these these
are European pigs they read they smoke
cigarettes holding the cigarette from
underneath these pigs can ride scooters
everybody I'll do this so it's
incredible it's the best tasting pork
chop I've ever [ __ ] had my mouth
literally waters when I read this [ __ ]
the incredible the incredible quality of
butcher box meat starts
with the commitment to raising animals
humanely and free of antibiotics and
hormones before they are slaughtered
yeah they listen to [ __ ] feel-good
music and then one day you just woke up
hey piggy look at that over there then
you get me all right damn Fred over cook
with a piece of with the peace of mind
knowing you are eating healthy
high-quality meat each box comes with at
least eight to 11 pounds of meat which
is enough for 24 individual sized meals
unless you're a tub of [ __ ] and you're
[ __ ] gluttonous and you go through it
in three days it's your choice you know
you want to have the meat sweats oh you
want to have abs it's all up to you you
can choose from five different box types
all beef beef and chicken beef and pork
mix box custom box lets you choose your
own cuts like my new favorite cooked
there Johnny I'm Johnny
I live on the hill every morning I walk
down to buy what I'm gonna cook that day
my name is Johnny and this is what's
left of the italian-american section in
San Francisco I [ __ ] love that guy
next time I go to San Francisco I want
that guy to come to a show
all right customer all right for $20 off
your first box and a package of free
bacon in every box for life for the life
of your subscription go to butcher
box.com slash bar and enter per a check
of a checkout by the way [ __ ] turkey
bacon all right that's a little aside
you know what I need to learn how to
cook because I try to cook it like the
pig [ __ ] you know or did it just bathes
in its own grease I like to burn it up
by the way you know my wife's I take I
take it off at about 15 minutes you know
mine I leave it in there for another
eight minutes
all right that's $20 off your first box
and a package of free bacon in every box
for the life of your subscription by
going to butcher box com / / and
Entering / and check out all right endo
ji don't mention that there's no longer
any excuse for wearing ill-fitting suits
everybody
you know something I just would just
love to mention something there is no
longer any excuse for wearing an
ill-fitting suit okay it's 2018 I think
it's time you [ __ ] Gras especially
when they're available at such great
prices highest quality lowest price
here's how it works
visit a stylist at our showroom and have
them take your measurements personally
or measure at home yourself and shop
online at endo chino comm choose your
fabric inside and out choose your design
customization submit your measurements
with your choices relax while your suit
gets professionally tailored and mailed
to you in a couple of weeks November is
Black Friday I think that it happened
meaning 2018 s lowest prices up to 70%
off everything the theme is all about
stepping out from backstage making
entrance take center stage your biggest
moment grand finale etc this week my
listeners can of can avail of black
price Black Friday prices by using code
bar at checkout that 70% off the regular
price for a made-to-measure suit plus
shipping is free
that's Indochina comm promo code burr
force up to 70% off incredible deal for
a made-to-measure suit one should go
custom you don't go rack hey by the way
I don't think anybody got trampled or
murdered or killed during Black Friday I
think they finally have it down
doo-doo-doo-doo me undies me undies
nobody [ __ ] died to doot-doot-doot me
undies me undies are those as fat [ __ ]
tried getting pressed up against the
glass your bellies round with your flat
ass you got a pancake it's not worth it
to get the DVD VCR at [ __ ] Walmart
you're gonna get bludgeoned with a fish
tank alright me undies this is the year
that you can finally tackle your holiday
shopping early and guess what you can
get everything you need for you and your
loved one
at me undies me undies matching [ __ ]
underwears doo-doo-doo to be undies
biondi's nobody [ __ ] cares that your
wife and you got a shark on your tape
and you tasting tart sorry talk about
why me undies are the best underwear
feel free to improvise you know I love
about me undies I don't have to go to
the store to get them how about that all
right I don't give a [ __ ] about your
prints they're comfortable they fit my
balls and undercarriage they're the
undies uses the coveted micro motile
modal fabric which is three times softer
than cotton if you've never felt this
fabric yet ready to experience pure
bliss in underwear form alright as you
sashay down the street filling your
balls swishing to and fro this holiday
season me undies will be releasing a new
print every Tuesday that means you have
no excuse to celebrate the holidays
right down to your very core but why
stop at me undies this year me undies is
launching their holiday prints in lounge
pants and onesies as well both are made
from the same micro Modell modal fabric
as their undies
seriously how can you not get you and
your loved ones a matching holiday
themed onesie this year I don't know
maybe got laid off the undies has a
great are bill my undies has a great
offer for my listeners for any
first-time purchasers purchase yours you
can purchase any me undies you get for
15% off and free shipping to get your
15% off your first pair and free
shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee
go to me undies comm / / that's me
undies dot-com / / one more everybody
stamps.com talk about how the holidays
are always the busiest time of year you
know people tell you you think you're
busy for the first 11 months of the year
and then the holidays come around and
you're like wow this is the busiest time
of year sorry I'm contractually
obligated to do that why do you what do
you have on your list your holiday list
I want the Beastie Boys hardcover book
that they put out or is it just Beastie
Boys I've never been able to figure that
out because they were always called The
Beastie Boys and then one time they go
the Beastie Boys where Beastie Boys and
then you go back and listen to their
first [ __ ] song it's like the Beastie
Boys right it's like you [ __ ] said it
what are you guys a bunch of hypocrites
like me I want the I want Beastie Boys
or I could say the what am i rushing I
can't use the word though I want the buh
and then quote Beastie Boys hardcover
book that's what I want I want that a
little [ __ ] peace and quiet where I
can go read it um wait a day babe our
bucka bucka barrel i think i actually
like their instrumental albums as much
as is the ones that they rap on the ones
that they hip-hop on I'm too white to
know anything about this [ __ ] but I like
that ban tobacco too
okay where am I how many errands do you
have to run well I don't think it's any
of your [ __ ] business
how was day of Starcom helping you to
save times this holiday season well I
can mail out all my Christmas gifts
right from the comfort of my own home
where in me on these beyond these bop
adapt adapt out back sorry that was a
remix how is stamp start I already
answered that as you know the holidays
are the busiest time of year am I am I
stuck in like a [ __ ] loop here
especially at the post office that's why
we use stamps calm it saves us so much
time during the hectic holiday season
with all the time and money you'll save
stamps gum is the best gift you can give
yourself this holiday season and right
now you too can enjoy the stamps.com
service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage
and a digital scale without long term
commitments go to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in birbee URR that
stamps calm and tabari
wait there's another read alright i'm
waiting for that one okay you guys have
listened to me read out loud but then
i'm gonna forget it if I don't do it I'm
gonna forget it
ah Jesus what do I do here what do you
guys I'm gonna let you guys vote okay
call in 1-800
my bookie everybody
a and we want to place a bet but you
didn't continue afraid you're gonna pick
the wrong team over there
this Thanksgiving it's finally possible
to get 100% refund on your bet if you
lose it but on your family with the
turkey day free play you can bet on this
you can bet the spread on either the lot
bears of the Lions why am i reading this
this already happened if it wins you win
if it loses my bookie will get Bilson
these guys are trustworthy fast and
helpful so you know they're good for it
new to sports betting Jesus Christ ok I
can read this [ __ ] here cuz this is just
you could read this anyway
new to sports betting and have a lot of
questions that's ok too because my
bookies patient customer service can
teach you how to gamble on sports sign
up this week and my bookie will give you
a 50% distillate bonus to jumpstart your
bankroll it's a great way to bank even
more money when you win log on to my
bookie right now and use the promo code
burb URR to get 50% off they'll get 50%
deposit bonus that's promo code bar you
need you don't need a promo code for
your turkey day free play that's over
that's over alright alright we're done
okay there we go
wink I could take a DDP dupa do alright
um there was something I wanted to talk
about yeah Black Friday I got to look
that up let's see did anybody why is it
called Black Friday it's an accounting
term you're in the black alright if
you're in the red well isn't that not
sensitive to Native Americans you know
Jesus
all right Black Friday injuries 2018 you
know some piece of [ __ ] lawyers also
googling this Black Friday death count
oh wait oh wait two injured in stabbing
at New York mall on Black Friday my
fault man shopping on Black Friday at
Walmart has a parent heart attack and
dies coroner says
man injured in shooting in New Jersey
Jesus Christ people is it really worth
it to go out and get it the [ __ ] deep
fryer or whatever the hell it is you're
looking for I'm telling you you shop on
Saturday you walk in like a gentleman
all right two hundred and stabbing in
New York mall all right now you wonder
did the person bring the knife there
just in case they didn't quite get to
the [ __ ] nerf football fast enough I
don't like making fun of people with not
a lot of money who have to go and do
[ __ ] like this but there's no reason to
stab somebody over a [ __ ] microwave
is there I mean you can shoot somebody
over a refrigerator but we're talking to
microwave here I mean you can get one
dose like 30 bucks
all right Syracuse New York two men have
been stabbed at a confrontation at a
Central New York mall amid Black Friday
shopping this couldn't have been about
this I feel like the violence only
happens at Walmart am I crazy
allegedly all right Syracuse police tell
local media outlets had happened around
4:15 p.m. at destiny USA police and the
mall management management say the
dispute began at mace at the Macy's
store it's not immediately clear what
sparked the confrontation well if you're
in Macy's I imagine it's the men
department and they were looking at a
couple of button-downs there officers
found one man wounded in the abdomen and
another man wounded elsewhere on his
body that means he got stabbed in the
groin both are in their 20s and were
taken to a hospital manager says laying
under a closed clothes rack just looking
up at this shirt that was so [ __ ]
important eight seconds ago police say
the injuries don't appear
life-threatening photos by Syracuse calm
and wsy our TV show a portion of Macy's
and another stores entrance were taped
off for a time
destiny USA managers say in a statement
the bloodshed was an isolated incident
that that's absolutely unacceptable
there you go buddy make make make out
make a strong stand and strengthens our
resolve to remain vigilant what does
that mean
that's the statement listen those were
the old this is this is the subtext of
all that listen those were the only two
people that got stabbed at destiny USA
which it's absolutely not acceptable to
stab someone at this mall and we're now
going to try to you know really look at
people to make sure there's no stabbing
motions towards another customer we're
really gonna get to the point in this
country where you're gonna have to have
a metal detector at a [ __ ] clothing
store all right man shopping on Black
Friday at Walmart has a heart attack he
must have got to the Billy best first
and he couldn't [ __ ] imagine his luck
Oh bill really I'm sorry what am i this
is a [ __ ] comedy podcast I have to
make fun of things wank all right wham
wham wham wham all right a man died
Friday after having an apparent heart
attack while shopping at the wall my
Wayne sorry this is the Walmart right
I'll take this job and shove it ain't
worked in here no more that's my Billy
bash you put that damn [ __ ]
all right at the Walmart on the US 280
in Phoenix city authorities say where
the [ __ ] is Phoenix looks like Phoenix
but it's not it's fennec City all right
little geography lesson everybody all
right here we go f ph f ph e ni x
Phoenix City Alabama Oh Jim give me a
break this is probably against [ __ ]
Bama [ __ ] uh War Eagle Finn it's a
city in Lee and Russell counties in the
state of Alabama oh it's almost in
Georgia it's almost in Georgia that's
the funniest thing about Georgia as they
look down on Alabama [ __ ] hilarious
wait lock them [ __ ] we polish our boots
all right a man died Friday after having
an apparent heart attack while shopping
at the Walmart on us to 80 and Phenix
City authorities said the death during
Black Friday shopping was a sad note to
the holiday season oh here's here's a
little side note as a toddler drowned in
his big gulp that he dropped hey
whatever it's Black Friday this is some
black humor witnesses on Facebook
expressing their condolences Russell
County Coroner said Teddy Venable 71 I
feel bad this is somebody's grandfather
had a heart in history of heart problems
he was pronounced alright so that
doesn't have anything to do with Walmart
yeah history this is the guy in history
of heart problems he made it to 71 god
bless him I hope for his peace of mind
he was a [ __ ] Bama fan rather than
Auburn you know just we had more joy in
his life he probably was I bet he was
that's what kept him going all right man
injured in shooting see where we go from
here
Jesus Christ all these show was a Glock
when you get here right man injured in
shooting and New Jersey mall Elizabeth
New Jersey the waning hours of Black
Friday were disrupted a New Jersey mall
on Friday as a man was wounded by
gunfire shortly after 8:00 p.m. that is
way too early in the evening to get shot
what did the guy who got shot say I'm
actually I'm actually I'm gonna side
with the shooter on this one
you know I mean you shoot somebody
around midnight then seen out here
you're [ __ ] drunk [ __ ] but you
shoot somebody at 8:00 a.m. I'm a p.m. a
they deserved it
all right the man was shot in the wrist
in a hallway between the Marshalls and
Tommy Hilfiger stores at the mills and
Jersey Gardens in Elizabeth all right
the shooter was has not been caught and
the victim is not cooperating with
authorities all right this is
gang-related this has nothing to do okay
there you go you know what those are
really only just one stabbing at Macy's
another guy at a history of heart
problems you know we went there that the
[ __ ] I don't know what the hedge
clippers were still there
you couldn't believe it he [ __ ] had a
heart attack no they got ya that [ __ ]
you know get shot in the wrist yeah I'm
not good what happened yeah I don't know
you sitting up with a bullet your
[ __ ] wrist you not cooperate that is
gang-related I'm gonna go out I don't
know I don't know Lin there all right
bill can we get back to the podcast
wait doll I'm gonna make you guys hate
that song sorry
all right let's get to a little so let's
get to some of the questions here at
work all right gaslighting hey Billy
truck nuts I mean what that means I
heard you and Nia talking about
gaslighting I thought you might find it
interesting that the origin of that word
comes from a 1944 movie called Gaslight
yeah somebody sent this to me this is
really interesting it's about a husband
that systematically manipulates little
things in her environment to get her to
think she's crazy
one example is when he dimmed the gas
lights in the house she mentioned to her
husband about the dim lights and he
would pretend that they were fine the
wiki page explains it well longtime lady
listener and loved the show I'm gonna
have to watch that all right go to the
page here we go let's read all right
gasps lighting I thought gas lighting
was you and you're like blowing somebody
up you know saying that they were better
than they were turns out it was the
exact opposite it's a form of
psychological manipulation that seeks to
sow the seeds of doubt in a targeted
individual or in a member of a targeted
group making them question their own
memory perception insanity using
persistent denial misdirection counter
diction and lying
I feel like persistent denial
misdirection and counter contradiction
that's more like that's more finesse
lying is just yeah that's just gorilla
pimping right you just [ __ ] punching
him in the face it attempts to
destabilize the victim and D legitimize
the victims belief instances may range
from the denial by an abuser that the
previous abuse of incidents ever
occurred oh this is what your parents
always all that never happened up to
staging of bizarre events by the abuser
with the intention of disorienting the
victim all right guess what I'm gonna
watch tonight I'm gonna watch that movie
gasps lady
gasps a gas lighter gas lighting movie
called gas light I gotta watch that
anything in black and white I [ __ ] I
really enjoy including one of my
specials sorry
advice for the fellow cubicle warriors
hey Billy Wonka now how did nobody ever
come up with that one
Billy Wonka I recently changed my life
by setting all my devices to night mode
permanently phone laptop iPad I had the
standard headache and I pains from all
these screens in my face all day long we
gotta buy those glasses that they gave
me the blue tint on him yeah it's to the
point now when someone shows me their
iPhone I kind of pull back because I can
feel those blue lights wrapping my brain
I think it's something you and your
listeners should know uh-oh you said
everything tonight Oh night mode oh so
it's not as bright in your face well you
know it'd be great if you showed me how
to do that I could probably look that up
I like the direction you're going and
sir any sort of paranoia is right in my
[ __ ] wheel off my first comedy show
what's the etiquette
now sit there and shut the [ __ ] up
laughs if it's funny if you want a
heckle heckle but don't be a baby
anyways hi bill big fan so glad that
you're coming to Germany I'll Jesus this
is somebody from another country
there's no comedy in Germany stop
laughing I have just bought a ticket to
your first show of the tour the one in
Cologne on June 4th of January by the
way I learned the last time Cologne
Germany was one of the number one bombed
cities in World War two and there's
still a few buildings that survived big
fan so glad that you were coming to
Germany I've just bought a ticket for
your first show in that tour the one in
Cologne I I had the best time when I was
there last time so I'm anticipating it's
gonna be another great show this will be
the first comedy show I go to in my
whole life I moved to Germany two years
ago before that I lived in Moldova a
small insignificant country that bright
stars don't go to anyways do you think
that on one of your podcast episode
you could take a minute or two to
explain how these comedy shows go for
you what does the ideal spectator behave
like should I bring flowers and give
them to you onstage
hi this guy this guy's gonna heckle this
[ __ ] out of me and how do you get the
chance to meet you after the show
it would be a real honor to be able to
do so thank you all the best to you and
your family and I wish you a great
European Tour tour listen you go there
you sit down you get yourself a drink
and then you listen to the comedian's if
what they say is funny you laugh or what
if it isn't don't laugh and if you go
too long without laughing then you
heckle I mean that that's a part of it I
hate to tell it to an audience member
but that's true and I think that that's
one of the great things about stand-up
comedy is the heckling it's a great
thing about politics too you know it's
fun but it sucks as a politician because
you can't tell them to go [ __ ]
themselves you know because you're
[ __ ] your sister in that [ __ ] pig
trough you Tacey [ __ ] that gets an
applause break in my business that ends
your career as a politician although
Donald Trump president Trump has shown
that maybe that isn't the case I am so
excited for this European tour I am I am
clean living Billy until I get out there
you know what I mean and I'm not gonna
[ __ ] it up either because I'm taping a
special and much I believe of next year
so I had my last bit of fun this weekend
I am done no cigars no [ __ ] booze no
bread no cookies no chips no no nothing
and I'm shutting it down during that
during the toughest time of the year and
I feel [ __ ] good about it eight hours
sleep and I'm drinking [ __ ] waters
and this includes right through the Rose
Bowl because I'm sad to announce that
the literally the cornerstone of the
tailgate can't make it this year because
he's got a gig the the five-star chef
Jason lawhead
unfortunately due to circumstances
beyond his control cannot be there this
year and it's yeah it's that's like you
know he's gonna be there next year
hopefully you know who knows if he keeps
[ __ ] getting gigs I don't know but
this is like you know I don't know I'm
hoping it's just this year but the fact
that he's not gonna be that I mean you
know he does his Reggie Jackson
impression he [ __ ] just crushes it
with the breakfast sandwiches he just
made it just it's like a massive you
know this is like Derek Jeter retirement
but well I'm just gonna say he's out
with an injury so we're gonna go easier
I think we're gonna go easier this year
do it a little bit differently but I'm
not going to be boozing at all I'm done
with this [ __ ] I gotta get myself
tip-top condition because I am NOT a
young man anymore and that that European
Tour is ten cities and ten nights and
it's just yeah so I'm and a lot of those
places I haven't been to ever so I
cannot go there and [ __ ] up I have to go
there and be you know I gotta be in my
best on my best behavior gotta help I'm
on planes every [ __ ] day but if I am
gonna be the last thing I need to be
doing is [ __ ] going out there acting
like a [ __ ] idiot all right here we
go
drinking as a college freshman speaking
of boozing dear bill I'm a college
freshman freshman and just recently went
to my first dorm party that wasn't held
in my room hilarious you sound like me
back in the day I'm an introvert so
luckily for me I got a roommate who is
social and likes to party otherwise I'd
probably be spending all my time my room
and not interacting with anybody well
that's good get yourself out there
doesn't mean you got to be an idiot
though all right you got a drink
responsibly
actually you're not supposed to be
drinking cuz you're underage look at me
I'm a dad now
I mostly kept to myself throughout high
school and had a few friends but never
really really did much with them outside
of school
because of that I never had any alcohol
I'm not much of a party guy but I wanted
to step out of my comfort zone so I
started decided to go it sounds like the
beginning of a really interesting movie
oh god okay so you go in there alright
hey this is the thing for all you young
people out there if you've never really
done something before the best thing you
can do is tell people that you haven't
just [ __ ] own it yeah I never I never
drank anymore I'm a little nervous about
it
I just want to go easy just give me one
here and there all lap but they'll
they'll like it it's when you act like
you've been there before
and that's when you get in trouble I'm
not much of a party guy but I wanted to
step out of my comfort zone so I decided
to go that includes you me being a
virgin you know where's the [ __ ] shag
never never banged anybody it hasn't
happened for me help me out guys
then it peaked in you have you get
brings people together
let's get him laid just don't go to a
hooker I'm not much of a party guy but I
wanted to step out of my comfort zone so
I decided to go for my lack of
experience it seemed pretty wild there
was lots of alcohol mostly hard liquor
vaping making out and loud rap music
that I didn't know the lyrics to dude
you are hilarious man this guy's a
writer you really paint a picture here
being the sheltered person that I am I
stayed in the corner and just observed
everyone else I was approached by a few
people that offer to alcohol but I
kindly refused that's good you're a
strong person saying that I would drink
something else I realized that the
alcohol would help me loosen up so it
was pretty tempting but not having any
previous experience with it I decided
not to smart man using your head even
though I kept to myself for the most
part I had some fun and I'm looking
forward to the next party I am I am a
pretty small person 105 pounds soaking
wet and about 5 feet 7 inches tall so it
wouldn't take much for me to feel the
effects I'm mostly afraid of how I would
act and what I would say dude you're a
very smart person college is all about
new experiences right so what do you
think should I drink the next time a
party at a party or gathering come
so what advice do you have thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself um I don't know you're
underage so I can't tell you to go drink
you shouldn't do if I how I would I wish
I would have handled situations like
that I just tell your roommate that
that's the deal I never really drank or
anything like that
and I would stay in your dorm room and
just drink a beer I would do that and
then tell your roommate to say hey can
you do me a favor just look out for me
at this party I don't want to do is say
anything stupid right and then on top of
that when you go to the party
don't [ __ ] don't get crazy as long as
you got it is only just sitting there
with a beer in your hand you could
really have water in that in the can for
all they know just be sipping a you know
but it's it's a very mature thing that
you're already considering not being out
of control so I wouldn't do that okay
you shouldn't drink if you're underage
you shouldn't I did it was stupid I got
a lot of trouble and it ended with me
getting [ __ ] arrested and me finally
[ __ ] smarten up really in the reality
is is you know nothing good comes from
it it's not good for you it's not good
for you health-wise it's not it's not
good it's just not good for you you put
on you're gonna put on the wrong kind of
weight if you do however when you're of
age occasionally having a beer is the
way you do it if you were mature person
Here I am 50 years of [ __ ] age and I
still have to shut it down because I
don't even know how to do it so that
know that that is the world that you're
going into so I think it's good that
you're very cautious having said that
there's other ways to have fun but you
know you want to meet some women or
whatever so just [ __ ] go you know
it's a strong move these we go there and
you're not drinking you know what I mean
but then it gets weird if you start
talking to a woman and she's been
drinking and then you haven't and then
she wants to [ __ ] hook up then it's
this weird [ __ ] yeah it gets it gets
[ __ ] weird man I would you know what
I would do I would explore the place
other ways to be social go to the
[ __ ] party don't [ __ ] drink
you know you'll be ahead of the game and
then I would find other other social
activities I mean you're not the only
person at school that doesn't drink you
know maybe you can meet some [ __ ]
responsible you know
woman have a good time that way there's
a lot of ways to skin the cat and I'm
really outside my element because I was
the idiot that went to the [ __ ] party
and did shitty in school so there you go
you don't have to drink you know
all right the press girlfriend just no
dude you're totally in control and
there's nothing wrong with anything
about you anything that you're doing and
in a lot of ways you're stronger than
most other people because they're just
doing what everybody else is doing which
is the easiest thing all right and
you'll see it in your lifetime when
every douchebag goes out and gets
themselves a [ __ ] robot because their
neighbor has one
all right depress girlfriend hello Billy
blue balls Billy blue balls so recently
I have started a relationship with a
girl and she told me that she needed to
tell me something very important that I
might not like about her she told me
that she had been diagnosed as depressed
for several years mind you I've only
known this girl for several months and I
don't know her circumstances is this a
deal breaker do I break up with her
should I ignore it if I break up with
her is she going to harm herself the
situation puts me in a bad position and
I am not sure what to do I think she
regrets telling me because she doesn't
want me to judge her also I am a younger
male still in high school and I feel
like I am NOT mature enough to deal with
this situation help is appreciated all
right okay number one anytime you have a
problem you should never ignore it
because all it does is just get bigger
[Music]
is this a deal breaker do I break up
with her these are all decisions you
have to make as far as you breaking if
you do break up with it is it going to
harm her
it's it's not your responsibility in
life is your happiness when it comes to
relationships okay and if you're in
something you don't want to be in in a
nice respectful way you sit down with
the person you tell them you're not
happy that you like them you just don't
like them in a way when you want to
continue and then you don't just not
talk to them you can still be friends
with them and stuff like that you just
this you don't to be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
about it however though if you know it
at the end all of this [ __ ] what this
purse is bringing to the table is not
what you're into then there's nothing
wrong with breaking up with them there's
plenty of ways for her to get help it's
not your responsibility that she has
been diagnosed as depressed but you know
I I would talk to her about it and just
say like you know what it's what it's
how it makes you feel just yet I don't
want it gently I'm not judging we all
got our our issues or whatever you know
I would just talk to her and learn more
about it learn how is it how deep is it
you know she laying on the floor for
weeks and can't get out of the [ __ ]
house I mean you know I mean that that's
that's a lot to take on
and someone who's out there with
butterflies fly swirling around your
head if you're not having a [ __ ]
problem you know it's it's all gonna be
up to you but I would not ignore it I
would just sit down and talk to her
about it and then digest it and then see
how you're feeling about it and whatever
your gut is telling you to do I would do
then if it's stay with her I would stay
what during if it's says to leave leave
but do it you know you don't have to be
mean when you break up with somebody and
one of the worst things ever is they
don't teach people how to break up with
people and this should just be a [ __ ]
class on that and like the Masters of it
are the ones who can break up with
somebody and they can still be friends
with them it's an incredible thing
button up but I you know and I think the
only way to do that is if from day one
you're just honest and you're constantly
checking in emotionally about where
you're at because if you don't and it's
going off the rails and you know it's
off the rails and the other person
doesn't that's when somebody feels like
they got dumped but if you're talking
the whole way along the other person
kind of knows what's good still sucks
it's still gonna be painful but it's not
that [ __ ] like where did that come
from and then the next thing you know
she's standing outside your [ __ ]
bedroom window with a pair of sharpen
scissors alright so there you go that's
the podcast it's a little bit short this
week but I got a I got to figure out how
to [ __ ] download Skype again so I can
do this other [ __ ] or whatever
alright that's it everybody hope you all
had a great Thanksgiving hope y'all had
great Thanksgiving hope
I will check in on you on Thursday enjoy
Monday night football tonight and once
again please watch I know you already
listen to it but if you haven't listened
to it the Joe Rogan experience I'll be
there Wednesday spittin Chiclets
Wednesday barstool sports and I'm doing
Dice clays podcast I don't know when
that one's gonna be uploaded I don't
know how he does that I've never done
his podcast but uh that's what I'll be
doing this week Kevin of being on Friday
okay get your Patrice O'Neal comedy
benefit tickets and lastly but not
leastly what was the other thing
Oh f is for family Jesus Christ Jesus
Christ November 29th Netflix please sit
down and watch it alright see ya